hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play probably
archery no hello mister naked man with
an apple for a head now I've played
probably archery before back when it
first came out of a game jam and it was
inspired either fortunately or
unfortunately by surgeon simulator in
that the controls are just so delightful
and lovely you'll want to throw yourself
off the nearest bridge and end your
torment write that in there but I'm
gonna play it again because there has
been an update for the retail version
that came out on Steam a little bit ago
I meant to play this before I get went
to LA but I didn't get a chance and my
voice was not ready to rage so let's get
into it I think I played target practice
before and I think that game mode is
similar so I'm gonna make my way down
clockwise and see what else he I'm mr.
Johnny I think this requires multiplayer
so if I can figure out something to get
this to play with another guy I'm gonna
do it poor girl I don't discriminate oh
and I customized my character so that
was my lovely guy
Sally mix Aggie tits is its name he's a
potato sack but he's got a lot of
potential ok ok so the story here is
this guy was so intent on becoming an
apple he shoved himself into a tree not
like that but in some way and now I got
to shoot the apple on his head we're
gonna control this okay in queue
shoulder oh yeah that's good I love it
these look like the arms from amputee if
you remember which came out soon after
surgeon simulator to try to capture the
magic of just the delightfulness of that
game so the point is you got to put your
arrow here you got drag it back and then
even more delightfully you get to aim
your other arm like so so I'm not trying
to kill this guy but I imagine that I'm
going to anyway oh god oh god oh no you
trust me right you trust me
whoa I was close there okay let's hold
the left arm right where it needs to be
okay so I think are okay so if I just
know I know how do i oh yeah got to pull
it back first and then I oh no this is
gonna this is my heard of it ah house
I'm more off down it would really help
if it would like reset to the position
that it's supposed to do and also the
controls are kind of communist so I'm
getting worse steadily I'm gonna get
this three hours god damn it I was being
a bit too cautious what I need to do is
I need to aim right for his ball I
killed him I killed him dead I'm not so
sad but I mean it come on you ready
mister man you look ready but you're not
probably how's that too far
how's that your farts right there oh oh
really
this sounds gonna be ah this is how
you're gonna do this ha
God dingus dammit how did I get like
this wait a minute no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no get a little
closer
what did i do this there we go oh come
on okay stay stay
oh yeah excuse me everybody for just a
moment here take two okay now Joe left
arm I need to do is I need to let go
okay way too much power there I need to
like it's not move the left arm until
it's absolutely necessary
the unfortunate thing is that the the
schnikeys the when you notch with the
right arm it's nearly impossible to it's
nearly impossible again in the same spot
because it just likes to go all over the
place so it's basically gonna be pure
100% luck depending on what I all right
yeah I hit the Apple everybody happy
with that one cuz I sure AM
time to move on because we're not gonna
murder anyone else until we're supposed
to murder them oh no oh no it's serious
Sam all over again
hang on did you wait a second for me
mister I'm not gonna stop till CIC the
weight of your core do you know what I
mean
ah I said looking Oh voted why did I
kiss blood you're so shiny bulbous in
every way hang on hold on a second
all right I'm dialed in here ready to
kill again don't make me do it
I'll make me do it come in here ah I did
it oh there's another one
ah oh yeah a second okay I'm getting
this oh no oh no Doug
Oh No well I kill them that part allows
moza do I still hear one exponent for no
reason
huh what's that was that what yeah yeah
baby okay I'm gonna try to get this one
from farther away get it I can get it
shoosh hahahahahahahahahaha
gotcha ah I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait
I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait I'm on it
uh-oh oh god I'm not gonna be able to
get this one yeah oh not too far how's
it nuts too far there we go
ah no wait how does he have a shield
that's hardly fair
oh no all right good job everyone we did
it yeah we did it
whoa take three Oh advance target oh I
can't even wait to dream a dream of
doing these we archive it
oh no not this why this Oh God Oh
remember as I was playing probably
archery like the controls came back to
me hey you're mine baby oh wow shut up
haha
archery moment with no dinosaurs this
game would be awesome with Dinosaurs oh
how cool would that be
developers if you're watching this make
dinosaurs nothing
make that happen write in the comments
if you want dinosaurs yeah yeah I got
one therefore I can probably feel
compass did not have to do this anymore
sugar bar the back your mind baby no
you're not cuz I can't remember cuz it's
gosh turned damn oh it's not communist
oh okay Oh
got it yeah I didn't now I'm gonna get
you my baby
oh you miss it all come on oh so close
okay I'm gonna go for that target which
is not moving or I'm gonna go for the
mountain behind it because I was barely
aiming for something we're off in the
distance a lot it makes you think it's
higher than it really is now or not or
not how about not how about it doesn't
is that's cool - ah Oh can't even hit
the target that's now moving how they
expect me to hit any of the other
targets all the way back George think
happy thoughts
think about pretty little Kitty's
sitting in pretty little trees prolly
the trees in the background that I've
been shooting arrows into and I've been
subsequently murdering it's not as quite
as right as I think it is it's not as
quite as yeah oh you son of a [ __ ]
oh not as high as I think it is huh what
hot is up now there's over Oh gotcha
[ __ ] all right I'm done congratulations
everybody we accomplished this
we are doing this together I'm out of
here goddammit warband
okay I couldn't hit like one how do you
expect me to hit that Manny I don't know
what you want from me came but I am an
oh no oh my god no way that's awesome
Oh our arrows will blot out the Sun Oh
God
I think I got one ah so cool Bosque oh
that was too far or maybe it wasn't far
enough I can't quite tell yep
and fire ha ha ha that's so cool okay I
think I found my game-mode by sheer
numbers alone I can't fail
alright I just failed but so ignore
everything I just said up until that
point oh no they're getting closer
sheilo REO her she blows I don't know
why I suddenly turned pirate but I'm
just feeling with my knob go oh no oh no
no no no come on ah
oh that was fun either way that was
pretty fun oh okay
somehow we end up still winning I guess
these are supposed to be like the
berserkers from serious Sam and they
self-destruct but I did not know that
alpha apples were that destructive
anyway
okay that's beside the point I was
pretty fun there's a few more game modes
here but I'm gonna I'm gonna hold that
off for later
so there's also zombie soccer and
multiplayer so I may try that with
someone else so either way that was
pretty fun hope you guys enjoyed it
thank you all so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
controls of this game